[Musique]
cette montagne contient des résidus
miniers rien ne pousse ici tout est gris
et stérile
on appelle ça une ald il ya une
cinquantaine dimanche collines comme
celle là près de quatre heures du mans
devant chaudière appalaches elles font
une centaine de mètres de hauteur couvre
un territoire de 1500 hectares et la
rivière bécancour coule au beau milieu
certaines contiennent des résidus
ministériel mais d'autres sont plus
toxiques elles contiennent des résidus
d'amiante et des métaux un sérieux
problème pour l'environnement
comment en est on arrivé là et surtout y
at il des solutions
en 1876 un cultivateur josé fecteau et
ses compagnons découvre dans quand on
est faible un rocher qui conseille des
fibres blanche
[Musique]
la trouvaille est analysée à boston où
on confirme que c'est de l'amiante un
minerai qui résiste au feu
sa marque le début de la ruée vers l'or
blanc
les compagnies minières américaine
s'installe et exploite les mines la tête
funding et aux alentours on creuse
partout
on détourne la rivière bécancour pour
vider le lac noir et en faire un puits
d'amiante à ciel ouvert
[Musique]
à la fin des années 60 on va même
démolir cette église pour déterrer
l'amiante
en fait en creux sur le site de l'ancien
lac noir puis d'amiante à celle ouvert
qui finit par atteindre plus de 400
mètres de profondeur
la région devient l'une des plus grands
centres d'exploitation et de production
d'amiante au monde pendant plus de 100
ans des convoyeurs crash des tonnes et
des tonnes de résidus
[Musique]
dans les années 30 on fait le lien entre
l'amiante et le cancer du poumon
l'industrie garde son secret
beaucoup plus tard d'autres études
scientifiques confirment que l'amiante
tue
c'est le début de la fin de l'industrie
de l'amiante au québec
les premières mines ferme dans les
années 80 la dernière en 2012 elle
laisse derrière elle cet héritage 800
millions de tonnes de résidus à me
hanter
[Musique]
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que les
ald subissent de l'érosion quand il
pleut l'eau s'écoulant surface
sa forme des ravinements et ça entraîne
des particules de résidus miniers vers
le pied des collines des nappes d'eau
peuvent aussi se former à l'intérieur
des ald et l'eau finit par sortir à
l'extérieur
on voit aussi des pans complets de halle
de décrocher parfois sur plusieurs
hectares un peu comme un glissement de
terrain
vianne quinzaine de halde abrupte et
instable exactement comme ici qui sont
particulièrement problématiques
elle pourrait avoir un impact sur la
qualité de l'eau de la rivière bécancour
le bureau d'audiences publiques en
environnement le bape s'est penché sur
la question de l'amiante et des résidus
miniers
son rapport a été déposé en 2020 et il a
eu l'effet d'un électrochoc
le bape constate que le ministère
québécois de l'environnement n'a pas
fait de suivi périodique il n'a pas
documenté l'effet des halles de résidus
miniers sur le milieu aquatique et il
n'y a aucune information disponible sur
la toxicité de l'amiante chez les
organismes aquatiques
donc on n'a pas vraiment le portrait
précis de la situation
le bape reprend les constats du groupe
de concertation des bassins versants de
la zone bécancour le gros becs
l'organisme s'inquiète de l'impact des
algues sur la rivière
ça fait presque 25 ans qui a pu d'âge ou
de matériel mais on voit que peu de
végétation qui s'implantent tout seul
donc c'est des sols à nu qui décroche ou
ex l'ont emporté par les eaux de
ruissellement la fonte des neiges vers
la clé est vrai qu'entre
le gros becs a pris des échantillons
d'eau en aval du secteur minier de
l'amiante qui en a partout dans la
rivière d'ailleurs les premiers
résultats des analyses de l'eau réalisée
par le gros becs sont assez troublant
[Musique]
il confirme que les taux de fibres
d'amiante dans la rivière dépasse
largement la norme américaine
on se sert de la norme américaine parce
qu'au québec il n'y a pas de norme
officielle sur la présence d'amiante
dans l'eau
selon les scientifiques les halles de
menace non seulement la rivière
bécancour
mais aussi les lacs en aval des
anciennes mines
les chercheurs vont fouiller les
entrailles de ces lacs les ont comparées
à celles du lac bécancour situé en amont
17 min
premier constat on voit que les lacs
reçoivent énormément beaucoup de ces
demandes depuis les activités minières
et la vidange du lac noir par exemple
ces sédiments les résidus miniers
voyages vols longue distance à l'étang
stetter au lac à la truite au lac
william puis jusqu'au lac joseph une
pause environ 25 km
autre constat les indes sont-elles
câline ça fait grimper le ph de la
rivière bécancour et des lacs et les
sédiments contiennent des métaux du
magnésium du chrome et du nickel
l'augmentation du ps des lacs de la
rivière ça change complètement
d'écosystèmes donc ça peut changer
carrément les organismes qui a dit le
milieu puis s'est répercutée surtout la
chaîne alimentaire vraiment des raisons
dans les lacs
les lacs se remplissent de sédiments et
perdent de la profondeur ils deviennent
des milieux humides
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait il ya
différentes options sur la table d'abord
une grande opération cosmétique
on remet gétaz lisent les ald qui n'ont
pas de potentiel économique ça embellit
le paysage et ça permet aussi de
réhabiliter le sol et de limiter
l'érosion
les sociétés minières ont confié la
tâche à deux entreprises spécialisées
dans le recyclage des matières
résiduelles on est allé voir comment ils
s'y prennent pour faire pousser des
végétaux d'abord sur le site de
l'ancienne mine lac d'amiante
le magnésium à l'eag est toxique
ça prend donc un apport en calcium pour
le contrer
ensuite on fabrique un sol fertile avec
les matières résiduelles fertilisantes
comme des sols faiblement contaminée des
résidus de désencrage et des bouts de
traitement des eaux
puis on sème des graminées
[Musique]
les graminées forme une prairie mais on
veut aussi aménager une forêt et on a
planté en 2018 des peupliers hybrides
ces arbres à croissance rapide font déjà
près de deux mètres de haut
moi
dix mille petits arbres ont été plantés
sur le site
des essences adaptées aux conditions
hostiles comme le peuplier le mélèze
l'épinette et le pain
[Musique]
sur le site de l'ancienne mine british
canadienne 1 on voit que la
revégétalisation est plus avancé 70
secteur de stériles ont été reverdis
depuis 2000 15 14 mais l'épinette
blanche ont été plantés et la vie
reprend
on a une fierté on a vraiment du
chevreuil on est un matin je suis arrivé
ce matin 7h30 très tôt il y avait des
dindons sauvages avec des petits qui
jacassent à trois mois parce qu'ils
aient approché trop et puis il y en eut
d'initier les orignaux donc les insectes
des abeilles donc on a toujours
mais pour les collines de résidus
amiante et les compagnies minières ont
des gros projets en tête un trésor
dormirait dans ses collines aux trésors
qu'elle estime 400 milliards de dollars
ce qui se trouve derrière nous ce sont
des résidus miniers amiantés suppression
d'environ 30 à 40 % de magnésium il ya
aussi du zinc du nickel et toutes sortes
d'autres produits stratégiques qui sont
importants qui ont une très grande
valeur sur le marché
la société asbestos veut avec des
partenaires extraire et commercialiser
le magnésium c'est un métal 13 ans
membres dans l'industrie automobile et
aérospatiale
pour nous c'est une richesse naturelle
qui est déjà exploité qui permet de
faire d'une circulaire parce qu'on n'a
pas éliminé ou non pas le broyer c'est
déjà fait dans le fond ce qui resterait
à faire c'est construire une usine de
production de magnésium dans la région
des projets comme ça sont possibles
partout plusieurs halde vraiment abrupte
et instables sont entassés le long de la
rivière et dépenses sont en rupture
d'équilibré
selon l'ingénieur miroslav chaume c'est
difficile d'intervenir sans risquer des
normes épanchements de sédiments dans le
cours d'eau il propose une solution
radicale
un premier ouvrage de dérivation frais
bifurquer les eaux des crues et une
portion de la rivière vers le puits de
l'ancienne mine lac d'amiante
l'immense réservoir se remplirait en
quelques années sans que ça altère le
niveau des autres lacs enfin grâce à une
autre kaman il retournerait l'eau du
puits directement dans la rivière
moi je ne vous les autres charges et de
sédiments avec la qualité de l'eau
discutable arrive au lac il ya comme un
temps de séjour ou sédiments même les
sédiments très fin qui sont d'ailleurs
le plus dangereux pour l'écosystème
aquatique spus ses déposants
autrement dit l'ancien puits de mine
servirait d'immenses bassins de
décantation
les sédiments transportés par la rivière
iris déposer au fond du puits et l'eau
qui retournerait à la rivière serait
relativement proche
les scientifiques et les industriels
semblent vraiment prêts à travailler en
collaboration pour restaurer les anciens
sites miniers mais tout le monde dit que
ça prend un signal clair du gouvernement
québécois et surtout l'appui du
ministère de l'environnement moi je
comprends pas c'est par le ministère qui
entreprend des travaux ici c'est pas du
tout proportionnée avec des organismes
bénévoles le ministère le ministère à ma
connaissance toujours absente
on a demandé à plusieurs reprises au
ministère ce qu'il avait l'intention de
faire dans un premier courriel on nous a
confirmé que le ministère n'a pas
d'études actuellement en cours sur la
rivière bécancour
puis on a précisé que les
recommandations du bape sont
actuellement en analyse par les
ministères et organismes concernés et
qu'un comité interministériel a été mis
sur pied et a pour mandat de travailler
sur un plan d'action mais on n'a pas
voulu nous accorder d'entrevue pour le
moment
là on est dans une situation d'urgence
ont même ça fait 40 ans que c'est comme
ça font qu'un temps 60 ans ça demeure
criant comme situation vous utilisez
d'autres d'autres visions
qui est une volonté politique de dire ok
on fait quelque chose pour contenir
l'hémorragie
des compagnies minières ont créé ces
halde à coups de pics de pelles de
convoyeurs et de camions on sait
maintenant qu'on peut remettre certains
de ces lieux dans un état acceptable sur
le plan environnemental mais ce sera
soit aussi un long et gros chantier
[Musique]